الحل المثالي لجميع مشاكل البشريه العالقه
من الامراض المستعصيه الى ازمه المناخ
هكذا يرى البعض الذكاء الاصطناعي تفاؤل
يتزايد مع كل تطور جديد يشهده عالم الذكاء
الاصطناعي اخره انتشار روبوتات المحادثه
الذكيه على غرار
لكن هناك ما يعارض هذا التفاؤل ويراه
المبالغا فيه خبراء تكنولوجيا يشددون على
اهميه عدم وضع جميع امالنا كبشر على
الذكاء الاصطناعي السبب حسب رايهم انه
عرضه للفشل ويفتقر الى الشفافيه التي
يحتاجها الباحثون لفهم كيفيه توصل
الخوارزميات الى استنتاجاتها بعيدا عن
النقاشات بين متفائل ومتشائم وعلى ارض
الواقع لم يحقق الذكاء الاصطناعي النجاح
المتوقع اقتصاديا على سبيل المثال توقعت
دراسات اكاديميه عده تحقيق الشركات التي
تتبنى تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي سياده
قدرها ثلاث نقاط مئويه في النمو السنوي
للانتاجيه العماليه
الواقع جاء مغاير كان اداء اسعار اسهم
الشركات المشاركه في الذكاء الاصطناعي
اسوا من المتوسط العالمي لا شك في قدره
الذكاء الاصطناعي تحقيق تطورات مذهله في
مجالات محدده الا انه ينطوي ايضا على
مخاطرها الى خاصه ان الجزء الاكبر منه
يمثل صندوقا اسود مؤخرا حذر يوروبون من
انه قد يستخدم لتنفيذ الجرائم الالكترونيه
ارتفعت اصوات تطالب بتنظيم التقنيه الصين
كانت سباقه في مارس الماضي اعلنت بكين عن
استراتيجيه الصين الرقميه تتضمن اهدافها
خلق نظام على المستوى القومي لاداره
البيانات والتحكم فيها ومنذ اسبوع استدعى
البيت الابيض رؤساء اكبر شركات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لاستكشاف فوائد ومخاطر
التكنولوجيا قبل تحديد كيفيه تنظيمها
مستقبلا وطالب البعض
بسيس وكاله دوليه للذكاء الاصطناعي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات وتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات